ce soir à 17 heures a débuté une
conférence débat à l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines les
étudiants en droit avait convié erwann
binet rapporteur à l'assemblée du projet
de loi concernant le mariage pour tous
une conférence interrompu trois quarts
d'heure après avoir commencé suite à
l'envahissement par des opposants à
cette réforme de l'amphithéâtre de
guyancourt qui accueillait à l'événement
vous voyez ces images si vous me suivez
en direct
c'était il ya quelques minutes anthony
rech pour la rédaction vous étiez sur
place vous est depuis revenu on le voit
c'était une véritable tension et on a vu
que la police a dû intervenir également
oui on pourrait même appeler ça un coup
de force a tout simplement une
cinquantaine de personnes ont fait
immersion tout simplement dans
l'amphithéâtre mené par des élus du
département notamment match et qu'on
manie qui était sur notre plateau hier
soir salle municipale à
montigny-le-bretonneux qui s'occupe
aussi de travailler aussi sur
l'université et ils ont commencé à tout
simplement crié des slogans comme
taubira tallois on n'en veut pas ou
aussi à chanter la marseillaise et ça a
été très électrique un des plusieurs
jeunes demoiselles étudiante de
l'université versailles saint quentin se
sont retrouvés à terre et en état de
choc
elles ont été ensuite prise en charge
par les sapeurs pompiers et une
quinzaine de policiers sont intervenus
pour pour tout simplement essayé de le
calmer tout cela est d'évacuer les
personnes qui avaient fait immersion et
les manifestants notamment ceux sont des
étudiants en droit qui avait organisé ce
rendez-vous afin d'échanger sur le plan
juridique de voir les conséquences par
rapport à la loi et changez donc avec
erwann binet conférence interrompu est
ce qu'il y aura des suites
est ce que les étudiants le bureau des
étudiants a fortiori c'est le nom de ce
bureau des étudiants qui organisait
l'événement a décidé de donner suite
oui oui j'ai eu tout de suite après un
le responsable victor hernandez 1 du
bureau des étudiants qui m'a tout
simplement dit qu'il y ait qu'ils
allaient porter plainte et que l'
affaire n'allait pas en rester là en
tout cas voilà pour ces précisions merci
anthony d'être venu sur ce plateau vous
étiez un présent on revoit ses images
conférence d'erwan binet rapporteur à
l'assemblée de cette loi concernant le
mariage pour tous et cette conférence
qui a été interrompu par des opposants
attention donc à un haut niveau national
et puis attention donc
les yvelines dès qu'il est question de
ce mariage pour tous la loi qui sera
présenté à présent au sénat au tout
début du mois d'avril et nous aurons sur
ce plateau le 4 avril gérard larcher
c'est l'ancien président ump du sénat
il est toujours sénateur il est
également maire de rambouillet il sera
avec nous et il pourra commenter ces
récentes actualités je vous propose à
présent de découvrir les autres titres
et les autres sujets que nous avons
abordé ce soir à la concertation autour
de l'aménagement de la zac charles
renard à saint-cyr-l'ecole dans quelques
années sortiront de terre 1500 logements
et des équipements publics les habitants
elles sont habitent sont invités dès à
présent à faire part de leurs réflexions
le département des yvelines consacre
chaque année 7 millions d'euros pour
l'aide à l'accueil d'urgence des
adolescents vous avez découvert le
centre départemental 90 placement son
déplacement pardon sont demandés par les
juges le harlem shakes est dense déjanté
déguisé tout le monde de s'y met depuis
ce mercredi il faut compter avec les
étudiants de l'université de versailles
saint quentin
ils étaient une centaine devant la
bibliothèque universitaire à l'appel du
bureau des étudiants a fortiori et
c'était juste avant la réunion qui s'est
déroulée autour du mariage pour sousse
environnement
le parc naturel de la haute vallée de
chevreuse vient de lancer son opération
nettoyage de printemps armés de sacs
elle les habitants qui ramasse les
déchets prochaines villes concernées
magny les hameaux
voilà pour ce point complet sur
l'actualité locale demain édition
spéciale du 7 8 des 18 heures toujours
en direct durant une heure notre invité
d'honneur sam karmann bande-annonce
petit goal est sûre vous mesdames vous
êtes déçu et je vais prendre comme outil
pourquoi se compliquer la vie ce serait
tellement plus simple de dire vous me
plaisez on va baiser
il ya tant qu'association
le 27 mars téléphiles reçoit sam karmann
le comédien réalisateur est l'invité
d'honneur du 7-8 avant de remonter sur
scène au théâtre marigny pour le bonheur
aux côtés de marie anne chazel et nous
reviendrons sur son parcours de son
oscar pour le court-métrage omnibus en
1993 à son adaptation de kennedy et moi
avec jean pierre bacri en 99
en passant par ses rôles dans cuisine et
dépendances et la cité de la peur nous
parlerons aussi de son engagement sam
karmann est le parrain de l'association
agissez contre les violences morales
basée à maurepas où il réside rendez
vous dès 18h en direct mercredi pour le
7 8 go sam karmann donc qu'il sera sur
ce plateau demain en direct une heure
avec lui nous parlerons de ses
actualités et puis vous l'avez entendu
nous parlons aussi de cette association
qu'il soutient et puis nous parlerons
aussi de culture puisque demain ce sera
la journée mondiale du théâtre je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée n'oubliez
pas qu'une reportages nos interviews
sont à revoir aussi sur notre site
internet à un replay et puis les réseaux
sociaux twitter notamment hashtag le 7 8
pour commenter nos programmes
bonne soirée